I think McDonald's has always been
relatively tasteless but in this case
they've taken it to a new level so this
is the crispy advertising billboard
which is put up next to a local
crematorium now I don't think they
thought this through some people have
said that this was meant to be some sort
of a sick joke you know you've got one
sign which says crematorium this way and
a big sign saying but crispy next to it
I honestly don't think they even made
the connection in there I honestly don't
and if they did it's funny oh yeah look
number one no advert has ever been that
funny right and number two what is
created at that crematorium tastes a
hell of a lot better than them
there we go I mean do you think